en attendant casimir suit vous dire
je suis désolé tu m'en veux pas trop
mais t'en vouloir ben quoi ben mon
retour mais je n'arrivais pas à faire un
paquet correct mais s'ajuste à vous je
ne comprends rien du tout
c'est pas lui dire tu sais bien
aujourd'hui que nous avons rendez-vous
pour offrir nos cadeaux à casimir avant
son départ pour les sports d'hiver
mon dieu j'avais complètement oublié
il va arriver d'un moment à l'autre mais
je sais c'est pourquoi je m'attendais à
voir quelques reproches pour mokhtar
écoute surtout françois que tu vas être
encore plus en retard parce que je sois
gentil je t'en supplie va chercher mon
cadeau je l'oublié à la maison aux
bonnes non plus pour être sûrs et pas
toi même mais c'est parce que j'ai
promis de dire une petite comptine aux
enfants qui continuent we
show car ton cadeau 1
alors voilà ma tite comme bonjour madame
la vie
comment jamal à marly elle va très bien
madame mercredi dit à madame jeudi de
venir vendredi dans ces samedi dans la
salle de dimanche
il est très drôle un quasi bien tu étais
là je ne t'avais pas vu ben oui c'est
l'heure de notre rendez vous exactement
et dis moi mais tu m'as l'air bien
triste bon ben tu ça finalement je me
demande si j'ai bien fait d'accepter
d'aller aux sports d'hiver avec ma tante
adélaïde est mort l'autre jour qui
captent adélaïde ah oui mais elle ne
veut jamais joué elle a toujours des
rhumatismes et tout le monde sait qu'on
sports d'hiver pour bien s'amuser il
faut être par équipe de deux d-wade
casimir est métissé exactement en quoi
consistent les sports d'hiver évidemment
les batailles de boules de neige en
europe un arrangement doutait il ya des
tas d'autres choses à faire aux sports
d'hiver aucun on va demander aux enfants
s'ils ne connaissent pas des
distractions lesquels
faire du ski par exemple ça tu peux le
faire tout seul
de la liste tu n'as pas besoin de pato
d'adélaïde
du patin à glace qui a très bien sauté
sur le hockey sur glace
du ski de fond
tu te rends compte de tout ce que tu
peux faire tout ça et plus encore
de l'alpinisme aussi dispo si
oui disent qu'ils randonnaient c'est ça
tout ça tout ça alors si c'est
formidable je ne vais pas m'ennuyer une
seconde mais pas du tout ils veulent un
cadeau pour toi pour moi entrer qu'est
ce que c'est une belle écharpe au garage
à bord couleur d'un joli je la mettrai
tous les jours j'espère bien dis moi tu
pars quand et bien dès que dès qu'il y
aura de la neige ma tante adélaïde et
déjà la montagne il m'appellera bouclé
les premiers flocons alors tu viens nous
dire au revoir avant de partir bien sûr
oui je coure montrer ma balle et
charmant les honneurs et je reviens tu
es superbe samu poté regarde mon pêcheur
juge l'expectative tu m'envoies chez toi
chercher ton cadeau pour casimir je
trouve pas le cadeau et quand je reviens
tu as donné mon cadeau l'eshop à kelly
milieu tu n'as pas trouvé mon compte ou
mal en somme comprend pas et coûte 3
soit tu as mal cherché moi je suis sûr
que la paix est tout seul est pas
trouvée
il était là j'avais complètement oublié
que je l'avais milla s'est désolé en
france 3 qui m'envoient kazim kazim tout
cadeau
voilà comme ça
dis-moi léonard tu n'as pas envie de
changer d'air toi commencé à changer
n'est pas allé voir ailleurs voyages
ouais voyage les moyens 50 cher pourquoi
ça coûte cher les voyages parce qu'il
faut utiliser un moyen de transport le
bâton l'avion le train pour se
transporter mais il n'est pas possible
de faire un voyage sans utiliser un
moyen de transport si un pied mais un an
là c'est un tout petit voyage c'est une
randonnée une promenade remarque il ya
aussi la possibilité de faire un
pèlerinage on pèlerinage c'est un voyage
conflit pour des motifs religieux le
pèlerinage des chrétiens arabes et
musulmans allah mais à bout des hindous
banc du grande île où les gens se rendre
dans ces endroits un pied à pied mais à
pied c'est très fatigant mais alors si
j'ai bien compris il faut d'abord que je
fasse des économies si je veux voir du
pays exact ou alors tu as le rêve le
rêve le rhin c'est un truc qui te permet
d'amener les chutes du niagara et d'un
pack de saint pétersbourg au zinc au
japon en une nuit sans quitter ton lit
mon lit mais on d'euros lit en voyage
quoi tu tues dans oui mais mais qui
t'empêche de rêver que tu voyages voilà
tu fermes les yeux on vous le dit je
vais partir pour honolulu aux mules le
voyage commence
tu fais ta valise
tu descends dans la rue
je suis un aérodrome du monde dans
l'avion où j'ai déjà dans les noix
aujourd'hui à
mika la mer et plo mme
[Applaudissements]
c'est le pacifique il croyait au dos le
moule et voilà déjà en train de danser
sous le soleil un moyen de queen ou le
retour
puis danse
non
m
tu es dans
tudor
mais non je tends pas au léonard jeu
mauvais choix dans un mois le nez
pourquoi dans un - je pars à honolulu ça
me plait mois cet endroit on voit les
anciens comme on commence à en allant me
coucher tiens tardy ou encore léonard
voir
et me voilà des bateaux
jusqu'à ton départ je serai ton
entraîneur 1 c'est gentil france formé
tu veux m'entraîner pourquoi les 15
minutes tu ne penses quand même pas
qu'on autres comme ça sur les skis du
jour au lendemain sans un minimum
d'entraînement mais il faut assouplir
que ses muscles les chevilles les bras
les épaules il faut apprendre à trouver
une bonne position un bris d'équipement
dans tout ça mais évidemment mon pauvre
kg mire bon écoute plus qu'on peut pas
faire autrement allons-y parfait alors
casimir qui te met en position comme sa
voisine a quasiment les bâtons comme ça
comme ça voilà plaisant n'est donc plus
en arrière les balkans oui tu te penches
à toute mise en avant les chevilles bien
souple blanche proches tout en avant
voilà allez allez les blacks ou tard il
faudrait savoir en avant en arrière en
règle tout plein au géant kazim est en
feu
bon allez il faut pas se décourager
comme ça allait enfin le ralenti
et limité voire progressent on l'a tous
assez difficile à jeudi mais de mélo que
jenny est un petit peu fatigué il fait
de réels progrès de gâteaux s'il pourra
descendre les questions assez formidable
qu'est ce que j'aimerais aller avec toi
on repousse alors là ne regrette rien
c'est tellement difficile l'empattement
il suffit simplement de un peu de
courage de ténacité de persévérance et
un truc à tenir alors sa formidable à
toute vitesse tue dévalera les pistes
des jeux a en france est toujours prête
bon je vous laisse finir à tout à
l'heure
bon casini reprenons aller allons-y en
position position avant litois sur les
jambes
les chevilles souples a plutôt un petit
peu partout en avant voilà le nez au
vent les bâtons plus en arrière plus
souple moins raide voilà accélère
accélérer accélérer un petit peu voilà
voilà sur la très bien c'est bien tu
vois c'est pas fatiguant du tout
pourquoi non plus
julie je suis venu te diront alors tu es
prêt à affronter la neige et froid ouais
et grâce à l'entraînement de prendre
quoi je vais descendre toutes les pistes
comme un champion
oui casimir est venu de dire envoie des
émirs c'est déjà l'heure de tourner par
pour les sportifs et oui je prends le
bateau dans un quart d'heure déclarés en
suisse l'avion le train vont aux quarts
et obtient la montagne désires tu
n'oublieras pas tout ce que je te dis
non non tu sois tranquille franchement
je n'oublierai rien puis on embrasse sa
tante adélaïde de notre part mais je n'y
manquerai pas oui je vous laisse sinon
je vais rater le bateau
attend la semoy le temps d'embrasser ou
moins du mois et est ce que tu as bien
pris des chaussettes et gantés poule
pourquoi on prouve pas d'offre à la
montagne des émirs des poulets des
pull-overs des chandails olwin on ne
vous inquiétez pas je n'ai rien oublié
ils mangent sans excès cette attente
fait des repas sains et équilibrés un
d'accord long mais je vous promets de ne
pas manger plus de trois quarts des
volga par jour et bien fils à présent tu
vas être en retard oui j'y vais
au fait
j'ai oublié de dire au revoir à monsieur
du snav alors vous le saluerai de ma
part eh bien on fera la commission
d'état toyota
est le facteur tu l'as vu
le facteur
je lui demandais de me faire suivre à
mon courrier il n'y a pas de problème
avant très bien aller auront un
quatrième haut surtout dans la fenêtre
fermée tu risquerais d'attraper froid
d'accord on voit des émirs des valises
me ben ali allaient
enfin les familles locales revenaient
donne n'ai jamais vu cela bien au revoir
quelle chaleur
et dire que casimir est en train de
mettre des poules over des chaussettes
des gants qu'il ressent le foie je pense
qu'ils passent des journées entières
ouais et des soirées à faire du patin à
glace fort et on peut dire qu'il en est
là
oui c'est toujours la même chose enfin
heureusement que nous avons nos amis
pour nous tenir compagnie oui c'est vrai
oh là là là là mais cette chaleur
quasi mir
kazemi qu'est ce qui était arrivé mon
vieux tu es déjà de retour de sports
d'hiver tu avais dit de faire attention
à la glace mais enfin infléchissent et
nous sans combat je n'ai pas eu le temps
d'aller jusqu'à la montagne mais alors
comment t'es tu fais mal
j'ai voulu faire une démonstration
alors je les sens du source c'est-à-dire
tout droit depuis la passerelle du
bateau
et alors tu t'es blessé en tombant bien
pas du tout ce sont les coups de bateaux
qui m'ont fait mal quelque coups de
batte au bain ce que m'ont donné madame
ou targue la marchande de poisson el
tabakh mais oui mais enfin tout va bien
rien parce que justin ventre que je
m'écroule dans son étalage de poisson
elle criait acheter mais bell ca inc
toutes fraîches et après que je sois
tombé
elle criait dans la mare est la plus
raide poisson
[Rires]
[Musique]